hey was someone named Samuel eat and ten
years ago today exactly 10 years ago I
was living in a rough count sort of
states with my mom I was driving around
old bangers they were always letting me
down costing me money I was driving I
remember a Ford purple ka in Walsall and
now fast forward ten years I'm living in
one of the most expensive parts of the
UK I drive a Range Rover I'm worth over
ten million pounds I own a castle and I
don't say that to try and impress you or
anything but people always ask me how
did you do it what did you do because I
went from broke to being worth over ten
million pounds in my 20s and I'm nothing
special believe me I didn't do well in
school and my mom was a mobile
hairdresser my dad a gardener and I'm
gonna share with you in this video
exactly how I did it so stay tuned so
when I was at the school I never really
felt that understood I never felt like
people believed in me and thought I was
gonna do well generally speaking my
parents split when I was seven years old
it's quite a bad separation
my dad was a gardener my mom was a
mobile hairdresser and when I was at
school I'll give you an example there
was a desk a big desk at school and it
was like kind of a special-needs desk so
there was a guy that was a few years
older than me who was on the desk gets
quite bad special needs and when he left
the school they put me on the desk now
even to this day I don't know exactly
why they put me on the desk I don't know
if it was because maybe they thought I
had special needs or maybe because I was
just had a real short attention span I
was I was flicking glue and getting into
trouble they wanted to keep an eye on me
but I just felt like people just
generally didn't really get me I didn't
think I was gonna go and do well in
school and be able to get a good job so
I just thought you know what I'm gonna
have to just rely on something different
maybe my hands maybe I'll be a builder
or something instead now my dad he was a
gardener maybe I could have done that he
changed his career I was around about 12
13 years old at the time
and instead of being a gardener he
decided he wanted to become a magician
so I was like that's cool my dad wants
to Bemidji
and he invited me to go along to work
with him for the day and what he was
doing was really interesting because he
hired a little market stand place in a
market and as people were walking past
he was showing the magic tricks and that
the ones that were going that's amazing
how did you do that he was selling them
the magic trick and I thought okay and I
could see them giving him cash now at
the time I'd never made like money so
the fact that I could see them giving in
the cash for these tricks I thought what
I can do that so my dad taught me how to
do this and what I used to do is I used
to buy the magic tricks off of my dad he
used to make a small profit I'm sure and
then I used to go to school
and I was to sell the magic tricks to my
schoolmates and make a little profit
that was like my first ever business and
the teachers didn't like yet the
teachers didn't understand it the
teachers thought I was selling drugs
they used to call my mom into them into
the school meetings and say I think your
boys selling drugs and she be like no
he's selling magic tricks whenever
almost like that's kind of weird at the
same time I had paper round's like crazy
as ulos a paper round's I used to wash
cars and I just wanted to make money I
think the reason I wanted to make money
was because I knew that was gonna fail
in school and I knew that I wasn't gonna
be able to walk into a high paid job and
I knew I didn't want to rely on anybody
I didn't wanna say to my mom hey could I
have some money for a car or for this so
I thought I need to do something my
stepdad my mom's new husband I didn't
really warm to him that much to begin
with when they first got married they
got my really quick and he was a an
accountant so very very different
nothing like my dad nothing like my mom
very different finance figures and I
didn't warm to him that much but I could
see that he knew a bit more about money
than my school teachers knew about money
because he'd been an accountant and I
think he was him who gave me the idea he
said plasterers make a lot of money I'm
sure was him and I thought plaster issed
and I thought I could probably do that
probably be a plasterer and for my work
experience instead of going and working
in a bank or whatever I went and became
a plasterer I went on a crash course it
was called
crash course he's got a plastering crash
course this course I stood a few days
long and I learned how to be a plaster
now I had to pay for this and I paid out
of my paper money and my magic trick
money but in these short few days they
taught you how to plaster a house now I
remember doing this course and thinking
oh my goodness plaster was make like a
hundred one hundred and fifty pounds
plus per day this is gonna be awesome so
I tried to get in with people that might
be able to help me
I did some free jobs I started now
fifteen years old I started advertising
as a plasterer and my dad wasn't loving
this idea too much because he was saying
no no no you're gonna come and work for
me as a magician and he's do quite well
now with his magic he's doing magic
shows he's working in restaurants and
he's saying you're gonna do this when
you leave school okay that's fine that's
fine that I'll do that when I leave
school but now I'm on the side I set up
this little plastering business I lived
in Warsaw and I set up a plastering
business called Pelle sore plastering
now the problem was I got this job and
I'm thinking I can't really do this they
offered to pay me 500 pounds to plaster
a room and I thought I don't know if I
can do this on my own so I said okay I
accepted the job and I'm 15 years old
and I'm plastering this room and the
lady who's the client keeps coming in
and checking on every few hours and I'm
thinking I'm doing this all wrong this
isn't work and this isn't now she wants
me to plaster the ceiling and I don't
add a plaster a ceiling they didn't
teach me that on the crash course so
what I did was I put in a little advert
saying I was looking for plasterers to
come and work for me 15 years old and I
start getting contacted from people that
have been made redundant or different
people don't know how to plaster I said
they said oh yeah how much you looking
to pay I was like 70 pounds a day
they said that sounds great I can get
started I'm thinking oh my goodness now
it's quite a lot of money to pay 70
pounds a day I've not got a lot of money
right now but I have been paid this 500
pounds what I said was I said a little
bit naughty
I said come for an interview this guy
called Tom I said come front interview I
want to see what you're plastering the
skills is like so Tom came for his
interview kind of feel bad saying this
but for his interview I said I wanna
watch you plastered this ceiling
hey so Tom's plastering the ceiling I'm
mixing the plaster off I'm mixing it up
even wrong I'm putting too much water in
then it's to thickness and Tom I can
tell Thomas McKean who is this person I
tell you who I am
I'm a 15 year old kid that this is my
first job I didn't say that
but but Tom plasters the ceiling I look
at it looks great the clients seems oh
just about happy I said to Tom Tom you
got the job so I gave Tom a few more
jobs after that and and then I started
advertising for pass-through jobs people
would give me the work and say I'll give
you 500 quid I'll give you 400 quid I
just push it to give it to Tom or give
it to someone else pay their 70 pound a
day Oh take them two or three days I'll
make a couple hundred quid boom that's
my little business that I'm doing now 15
years old and my dad's saying to me you
know I can't wait for you to work on the
business son my brothers two years older
than me he's working on the business
leaves called a 16 did manage to get ok
grades I got like I was like a BC
student so I did work hard at school
despite being on the special needs desk
and now my dad I'm working for him now
around about the same sort of time Tim
my stepdad who's good with numbers he
because he's good with numbers realised
that his house that he owns that has no
mortgage it makes sense for him to
refinance and invest in property so I've
seen Tim he's buying some houses he's
bought a few and I'm thinking hmm buying
and selling a magic trick you might make
a few pounds plastering gray you can
make a few hundred pounds but if you can
buy and sell a house you could make like
tens of thousands of pounds this might
be a better way for me to get more money
so I speak to Tim I'm a picking his
brain asking him what house did you buy
how much did you pay for it how does it
work and he's explained to me what a
mortgage is I never heard of a mortgage
and I'm thinking the things of Tim great
guy okay and he's telling me what he can
but he's not the best explainer in the
world so he's an accountant you give me
the facts but I'm not getting it so I
said to Tim I said where did you learn
about property and he said well actually
I've done a few property training
courses okay I said how can I get on
those training courses and Tim said I'll
intro
due to a guy called Simon who Verne's
from training courses I'm like brilliant
so I go down to this event is actually a
networking event and Simon is there he
was a property trainer and I remember I
turn up and I'm so out of place I'm so
nervous because I've gone from being
school well I'm not great academically
to being just about ok with my hands but
now I'm in a business networking event
so I've got this little soup and I feel
completely out of place I remember when
the networking was going on and I just
it was so awkward for me but I was there
and I hear about property and I thought
oh my goodness this is the way forward
so I signed up to some courses and I
started doing property training courses
I'm now 16 years old I'm starting to
read books I'm reading Jim Rohn like
crazy who's a fantastic mentor of mine
never met him he passed away sadly just
before I started reading his material
which Dad Poor Dad and I've introduced
this whole new world of business I knew
about being employed and being
self-employed I didn't know about being
a business owner I didn't know about
being a property investor or an investor
so my whole world is starting to just
move all these ideas are opening up
meanwhile I'm working for my dad on his
business and I feel a bit torn I've got
the my dad's family business never gonna
make me rich do you enjoy it a lot of
fun and in this whole world of
investments and property and business
which I'm thinking I don't know if this
is possible but I just nerve got
something in me that could make this
work so right now I'm thinking there's
opportunity now I've not got the
knowledge I've not got the money to
start investing into stuff a little bit
of paper and money but there's
opportunities there's more to making
money into business and investments and
I'm excited right now I've left school
school was a drag I'm excited and I also
remember going away my church invited me
to go and do some work in pathi Blanca
Spain in a drug rehab center I went
along did some work there I ended up
becoming very passionate about my faith
and I gave my life to Jesus when I was
16 years old and that was another thing
for me I really wanted to not only make
money but I wanted to support some of
the charities that are seen I spent on
out in Africa Zambia again shortly after
that and I'm so
excited about life I'm so desperate to
be as be the best version of myself I
can to give to help to grow to BER
unforced rate I'm like at the time I
felt like a loose cannon with all these
opportunities but I just felt like I
needed someone to hold my hand and guide
me through it
Jim Rohn said don't wish it was easier
wish you were better and don't wish for
Less problems but wish for more skills
and I just thought I need more skills I
got to get good I've got to get equipped
and I started going on all these
different training courses that I could
find I was going on free courses I was
going to unpaid courses also reading so
many books and I just knew that I needed
to dedicate 100% towards my business my
life doing what all I needed to do and I
knew that I needed to quit working for
my dad now this was a really horrible
decision had to make because my dad had
spent so much time invested in me and I
didn't want to let him down and I stayed
up until 2:00 I am stressing about how I
was gonna tell this to my dad I thought
about it for hours and hours but I knew
it was the right decision and I remember
telling my dad look I want to focus
full-time on the property styling stuff
and my dad I can't say he was happy he
was very very upset with me he told me
that others are let down and I was a
disappointment and it was really really
tough but at least it meant that I'm now
free to just focus absolutely solely on
myself my education my business
education and my property business and I
did a lot I did some stuff with business
linkogle an NVQ level two in business
and it was crazy I liked studying and
learning even academic studies but
actually loving it because at school I
hated it but now I'm like oh did she so
interest in finance and business and
making money and investment I was loving
it I joined a network marketing company
I joined I became a distributor for
Utility Warehouse and their business
plan and the personal development that I
got from that I just got to give a shout
out to Utility Warehouse I still you I'm
still a customer of Utility Warehouse
but just the training that I got from
Frank from though
guys and the contacts that I got
everybody despite me being now like 16
17 years old everybody took me seriously
even at the property networking events
people would take me seriously there's
no hierarchy anymore it's just a case of
well what value can you bring so 17
years old I'm now to get into property I
am managing people's properties for free
I'm saying to people all these property
networking events that are meeting
I'll find you tenants I'll manage your
properties and I won't charge you any
money now they're like what's the catch
I said the catch is I've got time
I've got courage I excited I want to
help you out but I just want to learn
about property so people would say okay
well you can find it I've got a room
empty here if you can fill that room I'm
not alright no problem so I would create
a little add-on spare room code at UK
take pictures of the room put the room
up get a tenant boom I think I can start
charging for this so I start charging
100 pound of time 150 pound of time
charge the tenants a little admin fee 90
pound admin fee my stepdad Tim I said to
him I'll do I'll do your I'll rent out
all your properties for free he didn't
have loads but he had a few and he had a
couple of HMOs in Wolverhampton so I'm
managing at his properties I'm charging
the tenants 90 pound to pop for me
that's not my style bit of extra income
and I'm getting in with landlords I'm
getting experience with tenants so I was
really grateful for that I knew I was
never going to get rich renting out
people's properties for free I knew I
wasn't gonna get rich even charging
admin fees I worked on a building site
for six weeks and I was plaster India I
knew I wasn't gonna get me rich it's my
plastering business which now to be
honest kind of almost winding down
because I I knew only gonna get me rich
I've got the experience and indeed from
it what I needed was I needed experience
I needed knowledge I don't need to be
meeting the right kinds of people but
the strategy that I really wanted to do
which is what everyone was doing at the
time when I was 17 years old people were
buying houses and then they were buying
them really cheap and then we financing
them I'm putting all the money back out
now I knew I couldn't get in any finance
I couldn't get a mortgage but I was
thinking as soon as I turn 18 I'm gonna
do this strategy a mortgage broker said
to me Sammy when you won't be out
through this at 18 I said
I said because you've got to be 21 to
get a buy to let mortgage it was like
stabbed in the chest pull the rug from
from underneath me so the strategy was
that you find a house let's say you find
a house for a hundred thousand pounds
you negotiate to buy eighty thousand
pounds for cash you buy eighty thousand
pounds for cash but that cash is not
your cash
that's a bridging loan that's that's a
loan so you buy it for cash on a
bridging loan but then the same day you
buy it you get a mortgage on it up to
its true value have a hundred thousand
pounds they'll give you an 80,000 pound
buy to let mortgage you use that eighty
thousand pounds to pay off the bridging
loan you'll be left with a free house
you've not put any money in you've got
to pay the mortgage but you put tenants
in that pay the mortgage so you've got a
house and you've got an income that was
the strategy I'm what this is amazing
how can I get one of these you've got to
be 21 so I thought I'm not waiting I'm
21 so I kindly asked my stepdad Tim I
said Tim if I can find a house and if I
can work with you and do whatever you
want I'll clean your shoes Oh
rent your houses out will you kindly let
me put my first property in your name
will you hold it in trust or be a
mortgage host or whatever we need to do
but will you just hold it you don't have
to put any money down but just so that I
can get on the ladder now Tim was really
happy to do that
he was proud of me he was excited to see
me win so again massive shower - Tim you
know what no one's self made and people
no one gave me any money Tim didn't give
me any money
my dad didn't give me any money in fact
he used to sell magic tricks to me my
mom didn't give me any money no one gave
me money people my mentors didn't give
me any money they charged me my paper I
wanted to go on their courses but what
they did all give me was they gave me
opportunities they gave me belief they
believed in me and my first property was
on the Maryvale Road I still own it
today
I bought it for 100,000 pounds it was
worth 120 and I refinanced it the same
day I bought it pulled all the money out
and this was done in Tim's name to be
honest I didn't get how the finance
worked if it worked at all on that first
property I didn't understand it all
is I'd negotiated to buy it cheap and
all these finance people are mentors
were saying yeah you can do that like I
was that ignorant it was a case of for
me it was a case of just saying if you
do that on a light switch the light goes
on okay I'll do that
I didn't understand how it worked I
didn't get investments but I just knew
the steps and I was trusting in the
process and thrown myself all in now
just after my first deal everything
changed because this was when the
recession came big time the property
price is now going down all the banks
and lenders mortgage expressed if they
went bust and suddenly it was a case of
everyone was screaming oh my gosh the
days of property investing over but my
mentors and wealthy people told me to
keep going
Warren Buffett says when people are
scared you should be greedy now little
did I know at this time during this
recession when everyone was saying to me
get out get out get out that was the
time I needed to begin in more than ever
because most people make money during
recessions I needed right now to go in
hard and to buy as many houses as I
possibly could with all these strategies
that I'd learned on these training
courses so 17 years old I bought one
house put it in my stepdads name great
18 years old I went crazy I was
networking I was going on training I was
viewing
ridiculous amount of houses I just drive
to an Arab and we drive into Blackpool
and just but I'm gonna spend a few days
in Blackpool now and it was hard I was
going into estate agents and they were
like what'd you use so cheeky you know
it was really really hard
my mom respects because my mom used to
come with me she supported me she helped
me and only sleep my brother who'd gone
down the path of magic working for my
dad he kind of teamed up with my dad my
dad had a business partner called Craig
Craig petty later on my dad actually
went to Brazil and left the business so
my brother and Craig joined up and
became business partners and Russell was
doing kind of well with with the
business on the magic side so respect to
him on that side and respect to my dad
me I'm now almost thinking I've got to
make this work my mom's believing in me
my mama's got to make this work during
the whole year of being 18 how many
houses did I get how many deals did I do
none I didn't do a single deal and the
reason was just because it was tough it
was
the recession was what was happening
property prices were falling really low
although I was trying to get properties
I didn't have any money I didn't have
any experience I didn't have any credit
there's only so many houses that Tim
would put in his name before me like I
don't know what I'm gonna do but what I
did have was I had persistence and I did
have people that were believing in me
when I was 19 years old I secured a
cracking cracking Dale didn't have the
money for it and I remember thinking
where am I gonna get the money from the
property was on the market that 85,000
I'd agreed to buy it for 65,000 needed
the money didn't have the money I was
networking I was asking all these
investors for it guess where the money
ended up coming from I borrowed the
deposit from my grandma my dad's mom she
gave me fifteen thousand pounds I put
that down to the deposit and I gave her
ten percent interest every single year
she was happy with that 10% interest
she again she I'm not self-made but my
grandma didn't give me that money my
grandmother loaned me that money
my grandma loved that loan agreeement so
much that five years later when I tried
to pay her back she said actually can
you extend it another year if that can I
give you some more money I've got
another 15 grand because she was using
the interest to go on-hook annual
cruises and her savings weren't
dwindling so she was pleased and she in
her mind I was doing her a favor using
my investment knowledge to invest her
money but in my mind I'm like I've got
investment knowledge but I haven't got
any money myself so she's doing me a
favor
that's called win-win that's business so
that was my that was my second deal I
then learned about Lease Option
agreements which is when you buy a house
now pay for it later I started offering
I started off from people 100 percent
market value I'd say to people I'll buy
your house but I'll give you what you
want but I'll pay you on my terms which
is in seven years and because the market
was really sketchy and property prices
had crashed
people were scared so people would say
alright that's fine as long as you take
on the mortgage and take responsibility
of the property so I started using
creative strategies that I've learned
from training to build up my property
portfolio it was a strange feeling
getting money from people like tenants
paying me money I felt like how are they
even taking me seriously as a landlord
when I'm
a teenager on like 19 and I think the
thing is they don't care how old you are
the marketplace doesn't discriminate
they just care about your house is good
so I'm I'm providing good houses good
accommodation my first house that I
bought by the way I rented that out on a
room-by-room basis I remember filling it
up and just thinking oh my gosh my
little family that I had in my house in
blocks which that I borrowed money from
my grandma my tenants are really happy
paying me money with my lease option
agreement the sellers are happy I'm
putting tenants and I'm making money and
I just thought this is crazy and I
wanted to make sure was well at this
point because I'm from a working-class
background and stuff I thought you know
what when I become rich I'm gonna help a
lot of people that's really what I
wanted to do I spent a month when I was
actually 18 in Zambia and I remember
meeting a young boy five years old he
just walked 12 kilometers with water on
his head he came back and I said 12
kilometers and the guy does worth two
days walk 12 kilometres to get water I
said why and they said because there's
no water in the village so they have to
go the nearest clean water is 12
kilometres away and then we just
thinking even though I didn't feel like
I was wealthy growing up I felt like I
was quite poor working-class family and
stuff it's all relative and I'm just
thinking when I get rich I'm gonna help
a lot of people and even as a teenager
like even though I didn't have that much
money my mom and my stepdad Tim we
didn't have a lot of money but we
actually worked we're working with a lot
of street kids in a really rough part of
Warsaw we lived in Warsaw as a place
called Lemoore and there's a lot of kids
in there really deprived just literally
on our doorstep and we used to do a lot
of work for them alongside the church we
hide out we used to hire out a big
conference centre and just play play
sports with them take them on trips and
actually we ended up we decided that we
wanted to live amongst the gypsies we
wanted to live amongst these folks that
were not quite as privileged as people
that were from 10 minutes down the road
so we moved we moved to Eagle Works
Drive in Lemoore really rough estate and
I remember having quite a severe car
accident when I was 20 years old so I'm
building a property business it's going
well
and the time was even working as an
estate agent I worked as an estate agent
just for three
just to get some experience to get some
contacts on working stage and I've got
my houses I'm full-time in property and
I'm having a really severe car accident
where my legs were absolutely battered I
had the car window smashed in my face my
car was crushed like a coke can and I'm
gonna be just thinking yes I want to
make money yes I want to be rich yes I
want to build my property portfolio but
jeez
life is so temperamental and I took
three years out from the air from from
20 21 and 22 years old for those three
years I signed up for Bible College I
went to Bible College for 3 years 3 days
a week I was travelling to Birmingham BB
l XB bli Bible College New College dr.
Reverend Robert pickles he was a
fantastic man and he accepted me into
the college and I studied there three
days a week
and then on top of the three days study
actually at the college I then that to
do placement so I was working in old
people's home and going off on mission
trips going to Africa during that time I
climbed Kilimanjaro and raise some money
for compassion charity and those three
years was really where I found myself I
found my purpose I matured in my faith
and I was only able to do college and to
pay for college because of the income
from my property portfolio now at the
time I wouldn't have really even gone
man saying I'm financially free but
actually my rental income covered my
lifestyle
so technically those years of 20 21 22 I
was financially free thank God for those
properties when I was at Bible College I
had to write and study a lot and and it
was a Bible College where you're
studying theology and faith and ethics I
thought well I want to do my
dissertation on biblical economics I
want to study money but from a position
of what does the Bible say about money
and is it ethical so I studied this and
I put this into a book by the way called
do the possible watch God do the
impossible and when I left Bible College
that write in that book it gave me a
real release from I I almost felt torn
beforehand in the same way that had been
torn between working for my dad the
ethics of working for my dad and the
excitement wanting to be a businessman
to be successful property investor and I
chosen to be an investor had the same
moral dilemma again when I was a Bible
College if do I want to just be
full-time doing charity work and you
know a pauper but helping people like
maybe a mother Teresa type person or do
I want to just be really successful in
business and it was this pulling do I
want to be a good Christian boy and live
a humble life or do I want to be wildly
successful in property and there was
something that wanted to be both and
when I was at Bible College I realized
that I actually could have both I could
be wildly successful in business while
also helping people I realized that as
long as when you make money you make it
ethically and you hold it with open
hands and a generous heart that actually
making money is helping people having
homes and accommodation which are
affordable is helping people and the
book went absolutely crazy on Amazon it
became a best-selling book on Amazon
sold thousands of copies across the
world and people were contacting me to
say can you teach your standing or can
you teach us about money can you talk to
us more about biblical economics so I
set up a little network called training
kings and training Kings was a Christian
business network but everybody was
welcome from all different walks of life
and different faiths or no faiths and
this went nationwide we had thirteen
different training centers so we'd meet
regularly all across the country in
England training kings training kings
presents to you a Christian business I
met reigning kings
I look forward to seeing you financial
freedom is dead simple financial freedom
there's a formula for and this is it
it's when your passive income is equal
to or greater than remember at school
when your passive income is equal to or
greater than your living expenses as we
have just had training kings conference
here in Zambia and it was fantastic do
what you love do what you know and at
the same time is doing that because that
kind of cost me a lot of money because
putting on all these breakfasts and
dinners and networking events someone
had to pay for this and even though I
was charging a small amount to cover
people's breakfasts just the
organization and the hotel costs I had
to pay for myself now I was financially
free so I didn't mind doing that and I
felt like I'm man on an absolute mission
and I remember I was at a wedding it was
an African wedding in the UK that my
pasta from Ghana was marrying a
Zimbabwean lady and I was at the front
of the church singing really loudly at
the front like I always do and I
remember glancing back and just spotting
a really beautiful lady right at the
back of the church and I remember just
thinking she just lit the whole room up
you know big beautiful eyes big smile I
just thought I gotta speak to that lady
I gotta find out her name and at the end
of the service I remember shooting to go
and find this lady and she'd gone and I
couldn't see her and there was an after
party that I wasn't actually invited to
and I thought maybe she'll be there so I
go to this after party and I think no
one's gonna notice and I remember
getting to this little community center
opening the door and literally I was the
only white dude in the room ok so and I
move over the door and you seen okay
everyone's definitely gonna spot me and
the groom kind of looks at me like what
are you doing here
and his face went to confusion - oh well
Gogi self some food and I was feeling
really awkward I was standing at the
buffet but there was that amazing
beautiful lady I thought I just need to
speak to I need to go and find a name
and it sounds quite creepy it wasn't
creepy okay but the thing is she's
tucked away she's sitting that looks
like with a family and all the chairs
and tables are really crammed and I'm
thinking if I go up to her and have to
literally squeeze past loads of people
and say hey and she's just like hi what
am I thinking the same I'm gonna then
just walk back past everyone but like an
idiot so I'm a bit nervous but I thought
you know what maybe this could be a red
diamond moment I just sent this could be
a red diamond moment meaning a moment of
decision that could potentially shape
the whole rest of your life no it sounds
extreme but it had that feeling so push
past everybody everyone moves the chest
I made a little bit of commotion got to
the table I said hey and she looks and
everyone on the table looks at me like
who and earth is this dude I don't know
what I was thinking this is where magic
saved my life
my dad's a magician I know magic tricks
I know how to do things with coins and
little and I pretended that I was the
magician I literally just said I'm the
magician it made sense I'm this white
dude in a suit and and they were all
great and I thought oh my goodness so I
did a couple of little tricks and then I
told them I'm not really a magician I'm
a friend of the groom sat next to this
lady and we got chatting for ages I said
where you from she said I'm born and
bred in Zimbabwe Harare but I now live
in Leeds I'm like my surnames Leeds like
that is craziness I said if everyone in
the area maybe I could take you over
some dinner and she was like sure I said
you know what I'm pretty sure in the
area next week anyway so we end up
chatting for like two hours and took her
out the following week or a couple weeks
later and I ended up falling madly in
love and I thought I want to ask Amanda
if she's interested in marrying me
because she's a great person
and I thought I need to tell her about
my finances I need to tell her that I've
got you know a million pound property
portfolio and I'm making pretty good
money through property and just tell her
everything and I felt comfortable to
tell her but the way I told her was
interesting because instead of saying
I've got a load of money and I'm
making lots of cash flow I said to her
Amanda I have not been totally upfront
about my finances she said what's that I
said I'm actually a million pounds in
debt now of course this is actually true
because I did have a million pounds
worth of debt which was mortgage debt
and I also had a lot of equity and I was
making a good amount of passive income
and I thought wonder how she'll respond
to that and I remember she said she said
oh she's okay she said maybe I'll see if
I can get some overtime she was working
as a surveyor quantity surveyor and I
remember just my heart mounted and I
said to her listen I actually am a
million pounds in debt but I've also got
quite a lot of equity and I told her the
full story of how I was financially free
don't have to work again neither will
she and she do even she won't even that
excites she just went oh that's good
isn't it I was like yes it's very good
and I'm very fortunate and lucky and
blessed to say that Amanda this lady
ended up accepting to marry me and we
got married the following year which is
just absolutely crazy at the time I
wasn't really working on the property
business I was working on training Kings
I was working on the charity I was going
back and forth to Africa all the time I
visited nine different countries in
Africa some of them several times
selfishly I was getting really addicted
to all the projects I was doing Africa
now I say selfishly because wherever you
go out to help people and I've been out
too many as I say many different
countries in Africa and gone to some of
the really rural parts and and helps
work in orphanages and schools and bring
water and food clothing yes you're
helping the people yes you're impacting
the villagers and and and giving
necessities or whatever it might be but
you're also helping yourself because
whenever I've been out to make an impact
I've always been impacted more myself
I've gone out to be a blessing but I've
ended up being more blessed myself so I
wanted to take out a small team from the
UK to one of my trips in Africa of
course Amanda my wife was going to be
coming but I got a little small team one
of the people that came I invited my
school teacher who was one of the very
few school teachers that actually
believed in me as a kid her name was
mrs. Highsmith and I remember saying to
her mrs. Highsmith I'd like to invite
you to come out to Africa to help with
some of the projects we've got going on
and she was up for it she was she's an
amazing lady so here's a little small
team together and we went out to Seoul
where Z in Zambia which is a quite a
rural town in Zambia and we went about
40 minutes from Seoul where Zee to this
very very small village and this was the
village where I met that small boy who
hadn't in his village had any drinking
water and we provided a borehole in the
village and not only was it was it
impacting the people but it was
impacting me and now my team and I just
thought this is just incredible I want
to do this more I want to make more
money I want to buy more houses
I just want to scale big I want to grow
and I thought how can I make money fast
through property because the thing is if
property is even though it's a great way
to make money you've got to save money
first and then you buy the property or
even if you do it strategically the
lease option agreement getting rents of
people it's not fast cash it just it
just increases your monthly income but
how can I get some faster cash how can I
because I want I want to grow the
charity side of things the projects I
want to get the charity registered
because at this
point it was not registered I wanted to
register it so that people could then
donate money into it properly so that
it's all done properly but I realized
that that was going to take not just
money to register charity but a lot of
time and resources because registering a
charity is not like just registering a
business it can take a lot of time and I
really wanted to just grow so I thought
I know what I'll do these people from
the crash course and from training kings
and all these investors and all these
times I'm doing these talks and I'm
getting more known that wanna do
property what I'll do is I will offer to
take them out in my car for a day show
them around some really good property
investments that are for sale and if
they like them and if they buy them they
can pay me a fee because I'd work just
an estate agent where you just sell
houses but when you work as an estate
agent that is seller gives you the money
but what my strategy is really good at
is finding good brilliant investments so
I thought if I can find brilliant
investments I can sell them to investors
and charge a fee hi I'm Samuel lanes
we're here in Wolverhampton we've got
the city centre just about five minutes
away
Bentley bridge
look around the house and all our tubers
then we're out here with a couple of new
up-and-coming property investors we've
got five properties that all the market
to look at today and hopefully by the
end of the day when I found a full
bedroom HMO for less than 100 grams that
is in good condition so it's good a good
day I even do it excited
text alert today we're going to be going
out with two investors
so I started doing deal sourcing I set
up a little company called buy low rent
high limited packaging deals of selling
them to investors and this company
became so successful I started selling
so many property deals it was just like
I couldn't even cope I had more
investors wanting deals than I could
physically find deals I've sold over 200
deals and it just blew up and I used all
of that money to not only build my own
portfolio even bigger but also to help
with the charity work that I was doing
in Africa also to fund training Kings
and it was 25 years old when I actually
became a cash millionaire 25 years old
it became a millionaire and at this
point life just felt really really good
because I've gone from being a broke
teenager that doesn't know anything
about property and go into these
networking events and hoping people will
take me seriously having the same
network meetings saying Samuel can you
come and be the speaker with training
Kings that side of things was going
crazy so I've now got full-time staff
that I'm paying training cleans is not
making any money and I'm teaching people
about business and about finance and
about how to do it with ethics as a
Christian and people are literally
through training Kings they're setting
up charities and they're setting up
enterprises and social enterprises and
doing works and it was absolutely
amazing what was happening but people
would always say to me teach us about
property you know teaches about property
and I didn't really want training Kings
the Christian Business Network to be
training Kings aka property so I started
doing alongside my training Kings I
started doing some small events called
property investors crash courses and
these were just one day crash courses a
bit like my plastering crash course that
I did as a teenager I said look I've
done quite well in property I'll teach
you everything in property and I'll run
it as a one day course separate two
training kinks and if anyone's
interested this is it
and that became really popular people
would pay 250 pounds to attend the
one-day course and that to be honest
didn't really make me much money but it
just covered costs of hotels and food
and different things like that and it
was good I wasn't particularly a
fantastic host sometimes I remember one
time there were we booked a hotel room
and I got to the event and I got there
about an hour early and the door was
locked and it was probably because I
hadn't hired an expensive hotel room and
I was thinking oh my goodness and people
started arriving and I was saying hi and
they're like what time we gonna go in
and the door was locked and I'm frankly
phoning beyond the same come on you need
to let me in it was really Stewart there
was some really interest in stressful
times but the property investors crash
course really began to get popular and
people would spread the word and people
would do deals as a result of coming to
the crash course and start doing
property and for themselves and that was
really satisfying I really enjoyed doing
that and people wanted to learn from me
and I would do the crash course but I
had this thing where even though I would
charge for the crash course it's 250
pounds I didn't want to sell at the
crash course because when I when I was
17 18 I did a lot of training courses
every time I'd go to a training course
same thing they do a special offer and
they'd sell it to me in a blog and I buy
because I'd be really emotional
I'd want to become financially free
annoyed by it but then when I went on
the advance train and they did the same
thing again and they just say if you
really want to know you have to do this
and then I'd buy again and if you're it
and I ended up spending tens of
thousands of pounds when I was really
really struggling financially and some
of the training was really good and it
got me to around today but some of the
training was not too good and I had this
complex around selling especially a
training program I didn't want to do it
now I'm 25 years old I'm a millionaire
I'm running crash courses I'm charging
250 pounds and that's it and these
students would say can you do some more
training can you mentor me can you do
some advanced stuff and I'd always say
nope that's it one day crash course
undone and I remember one of my mentors
said to
he said what why do you not offer any
advanced training fees students I said
no I'm not allowed to do that because I
don't want to sow it I wanted to teach
everything at the crash course he said
okay he said does some of your students
come to the crash course and then go and
pay for advanced training elsewhere do
they join other people's masterminds
other people's Academy to other peoples
and I said I thought about it I thought
they actually do because a lot of people
would message me and they say Samuel
thank you for getting me started in
property I've now done mentoring or
advanced training with this person but
you were the one that got me started and
I was thinking now yeah they do it's
okay he said could you teach it better
than those people I said yes he said
would you be able to do it for the same
price or cheaper I said yes he said well
you know what Samuel in trying to be
kind and not salesy and all that he said
you're actually robbing people and your
discs serving people I was in Thailand
at the time when my mentor said this to
me and I just thought this is crazy this
was December 2016 I'm in Thailand I've
got a crash course the next month pop
and I'm just about to start promoting at
250 pounds and I thought you know what
here's what I'm gonna do
he's right I am disturbing people people
are coming to my crash because they're
not gonna learn everything him one day
here's what I'll do I'll do the crash
course for two days I'll make it free
I'll get lots of people to come it's
free but then I'll say if you want to do
advanced training or mentoring and I'll
offer a service where they can do
advanced training and I did that and I
had a hundred and twenty six people
January 2017 in the room it was two days
it was free and then I offered I said if
you want to do more training and I made
an offer and you know what it felt quite
good because I knew that these people
needed it and wanted it and if I didn't
offer it would go and do it with someone
else elsewhere and pay more and get less
of an experience and I had 22 people 22
people registered for a program that I
created called the deal finding
extravaganza that was a three day
advanced training program
I can invest in property afford to get
into it get a return big funds the
biggest thing today was conferred
Tiffany's members searching to market
their actual market revive new corner
pages and those people most of them went
on to do deals and become successful and
now credit me is part of their journey I
just thought this is great I got
addicted to that feeling and I was
thinking I really want to scale I really
want to grow and then my wife Amanda got
pregnant and we moved into a little barn
conversion
out in the country and there
Featherstone in Wolverhampton and I
thought you know what can i really be
bothered to do all this training can i
really be bothered to do the youtube
videos and to do crash courses and
especially when the crazy thing is when
you do a crash course and you teach
people for free and you do YouTube
videos yep there was always there would
always be people that would come or that
would comment on YouTube and say like oh
you're just trying to exploit people
though you're not the real deal or
you're a fraud you're a scammer you're a
heavy sales person and you're this and
to be honest it kind of used to get to
me a little bit I think ah just because
I'm allowed kind of personality and the
way I am might seem a bit like salesy or
a bit kind of American or I just thought
I don't want to be branded with that
brush because that's not my heart that's
not what I started my training business
as training Kings which was
non-for-profit just because I want to
help people I didn't wanna be one of
those rich people but they hid away and
I'm trying to help people and I'm giving
people content and for information and
people are just hating on me because of
it and of course it was only the odd
person would hate I always say for
everyone hate you've helped 100 but I
thought do I really want to do this do I
really want to put my head above the
parapet for someone to come and try and
chop it off all over and over again or
shall I just retire on a millionaire
I've got a nice property portfolio
that's giving me a good income where I
never have to work again shows retire
now I've got a beautiful wife who's prey
so I told Amanda I don't think I'm gonna
carry on with the training business I'm
gonna calm down on the deal selling side
of things and maybe just package himself
one or two deals a month I'm just gonna
do a few charity shows with my dad or
whoever working for my brother for fun
don't want any money I just want to live
life fun free easy retirement type life
25 millionaire 26 now and Mandy said
I'll support you in that that's fine so
we had Ruby Ruby Joy Leeds was born in
October 2017 and I kind of retired at
that point and four months after
retiring and Anna said to me she said
are you okay I said yeah I'm fine she
said you've not been yourself the last
few months like what's going on and I
realized that I wasn't men I wasn't
meant for retirement I was getting itchy
feet I had so much pent-up energy I just
done a cage fight a charity cage fight
because I wanted to let some steam off
and I'm honey just said I don't even
want you around the house right now like
you just hopping around like she said
you need to go and sell some deals you
need to go make some money you need to
start traveling you need to you need to
start doing crash courses again and
getting on stage I said you think so she
said yeah so I said okay and I spoke to
my brother I said to him man I'm
thinking of getting back doing crash
courses again and thinking they're doing
the going back into property and
actually growing my business rather than
just getting lazy and I said how you
doing in business and he was doing
really well on his business he was
running slightly unusual with Craig they
were really good entertainment a you'll
see they had lots of staff they were
doing lots often owed in over 200 shows
a month between between amongst the
whole company I thought you know I want
to grow big I want to scale on my
business I want to leave a legacy I want
to help people I want to register my
charity but I can't really do this alone
I want a business partner so I offered
Russell a business partnership I said
why don't you work with me leave the
magic business come and work with me
we'll grow the property business will
scale it will train as many people as we
can in property oh I'll take YouTube
more seriously I'm gonna do
et video every single day and let's do
this together and with a little bit of
persuasion Russel agreed and Russell
took his business acumen he's big
thinking of lots of staff and lots of
with my knowledge of property and my
ability to make a lot of money in
property but we brought that together
and we scaled the business and as soon
as Russell started working with me he
was like we need to do bigger deals I
was like no I don't think so I like
these little small HMOs you guys know
bigger deals and Russell ended up
working with me and we bought the castle
we bought ribs foot house which is an
absolutely fabulous grade two-star
listed building with a gross development
value now of 6.35 million pounds so
Russell's big think I got a credit here
because he found the castle remember
Russell saying to me we need to get
bigger mentors and I'm like yeah but
this mentor that I've had for like eight
years is really good and what's the
first farming keep that but it's so I
started just really going to new heights
Russell said we were only getting 200
people at the crash course we need to
get bigger venues I'm like how big do
you reckon we should get so we started
we booked out the Ibis Hotel in London
that holds 1,200 people thinking surely
we're not gonna fill this we're not
gonna fill this I've only ever run
events for like 250 people max but as we
did as we got a bigger venue and we just
had faith and believed that we'd fill it
we did and I mean Russell was just like
thinking yeah this is this is that where
it should be out I'm thinking surely
this is a one-off event that this won't
happen again
Russell says let's book the abyss Hotel
again next week I'm like come on dude
that's ridiculous we booked the abyss
again next week we sell it out thousand
people this became the new normal so now
it's at a stage where we're talking I'm
planning me my wife for talking we're
celebrating and it's like how can we
continue to grow continue to help people
continue to bring change continue to
make profit like one of the next steps
we're doing bigger deals we're doing
bigger events I'm now getting invited to
go and speak all these conferences I
haven't even got time I'm winning awards
I'm like I don't even remember applying
for that award
it's just that I'm getting calls from
people that are celebrities people that
I used to watch as a kid on the TV and
now phoning me up
personally to say can I talk to you
about property can we do deals together
so it right at this point now I'm like
20 27 28 I'm pinching myself and me and
Russell are talking and one of our one
of our directors of the company said I
think that we need to as a company I
think that we need to move I'm like what
do you mean move I think we need to move
offices I think we need to move
locations I look at Russell and Russell
looks at me and what suppose we've
already spoken and I agree I'm like we
can't move from Hilton Hall in
Wolverhampton and I'm like what do you
think he moved more central to the city
of Wolverhampton and Russell said we're
thinking that we should probably move to
London London
II think we should move to LA I'm a
black country boy I'm born and bred in
like Warsaw Wolverhampton up London I
can't imagine living there
so I said I'll tell you what I'll go and
look at some houses for rent and I'll go
and look at some offices and get a vibe
and see how I feel now at this point
I've got meetings in London back and
forth all the time so last year we made
a real bold move and even though
everything's really expensive and it's
really different we moved to London and
we spoke to Amanda's brother this is
really exciting who is a property
chartered surveyor and we said hey do
you want to come in on the business so
he's now come on the property side of
the business and he's moved so we live
just outside of London in
Buckinghamshire the family are close by
me and Amanda have now a second child so
we've had Ruby joy we now got Luke Luke
Samuel Leeds
and last year we made over two million
pounds clean profit across the
businesses turned over just shy of ten
million pounds but it's not about how
much money you make it's about what that
money can do and how far you can help
people and we just had a charity
Samuel Leeds foundation finally we've
got the Commission number which for me
is just absolutely incredible we're in
the process of working with the school
we're looking to build a school in
Uganda and there's just so much crazy
good exciting stuff going on has it all
been easy no has it been challenging yes
my net worth is now over 10 million
pounds and like I can't believe it if
I'm honest I'm 29 years old
did I intend to become a
multi-millionaire no I didn't I intended
to become financially free and property
to just give me more time I intended
just to make a decent living because I
knew that I wouldn't be able to do it
with school qualifications and now I'm
on a mission all I want to do a few
things I want to bring financial
education into schools I want people to
realize that if they're not good in
school or if they don't like their job
or if they don't that that there's
another way
and that's property and for me property
has changed my life and I want to
publicly thank those that have stood
with me thank those that have helped me
that have opened doors for me
no one's self-made it's the people of
given opportunities all I've done is
taken those opportunities believed I
could do it and I'm grateful I'm
grateful to be alive I'm grateful to my
family I'm grateful to my customers I'm
grateful to my staff I'm also excited
about the next few years so I'll be
doing an update no doubt in another year
or another few years time and who knows
what's gonna have happened but hey thank
you for watching this video thank you
for being a subscriber of the YouTube
channel because YouTube's kind of almost
become my life now I love documenting my
journey so just thank you folks and
remember if I can do it so can you